a very difficult time for this community
it was just late yesterday that the
police department released the names of
the people who were either injured or
killed which include 13 people they
range in age from 20 to 86 years old
they include people like retired buffalo
police officer aaron salter the security
guard at tops on the day of the shooting
as well as people like ruth whitfield
the mother of the city's retired fire
commissioner many people here in buffalo
morning and still in shock
why this tops on this side of town
there's a reason why he picked this
location you have the black secluded to
the east side if you live over here this
is the only grocery store you really
have access to no one could have
expected the chaotic scene that unfolded
at this top's grocery store in buffalo i
couldn't get out the back door i kept
hearing them closer and closer kishanti
atkinson says she was working at the
cash register when the gunman opened
fire she hid with co-workers in a back
conference room and they barricaded the
door with a table so you're in there
praying that he doesn't come yeah and i
was i was instructing all my co-workers
to just please be quiet so he won't hear
us the shooting started around 2 30 on
saturday afternoon possible
[Applause]
police say the accused gunman had driven
roughly 200 miles from conklin new york
to kill black people and that he was
spotted there friday the day before the
shooting if you ask me right now is that
kid i talked to on friday races
i would tell you no brady lewis said he
spoke to the suspected gunman for more
than an hour that day outside the
supermarket he said the topics range
from time travel to critical race theory
you think he would have tried to kill
you i don't know because obviously he
don't like black people but i don't know
if he would shot me or not authorities
called the alleged gunman a racially
motivated violent extremist he took my
sister
he told my sister my sister who i talk
to every day among the victims is 72
year old catherine massey whose sister
and niece took us into her home no i'm
just saying
some of her favorites yeah
they told us she was a beloved pillar of
the buffalo community kat was our
cheerleader she was a matriarchal family
she was
you need something if she could do it
she would do it for you we also spoke to
tops employee zaire goodman who survived
a gunshot wound to the neck the 20 year
old chose not to be on camera i can see
you kind of bouncing up and down and
what's the
emotion that you're feeling right now
discomfort
sadness
maybe a bit of regret
regret
why
i wonder why out of all the people that
the three people that were spared i was
one of them
and zaire's mother calling her son
survival divinely orchestrated um and
that's something a lot of people here
will be leaning on their faith yeah a
lot of them saying this place will never
be the same others saying well it will
never be the same it may actually be
better they want to bounce back it's a
resilient community you lived and worked
here for three years it's very hard to
summarize a place in just a few words
but what would you want people to know
about this area of buffalo i think it's
known as the city of good neighbors and
that's what you're going to see more of
today people will be coming out
trying to make sure everyone's okay
i'm talking to community organizers
right now who are saying they want to
make sure that grief counselors are on
hand because this was a traumatic event
you had people watch people being
murdered young people a lot of folks
right now just dealing with
the violence
and the threat the threat that we
continue to talk about to see an 18 year
old sort of radicalized online over the
period of the last two years during the
pandemic
says a lot and it says a lot about what
we need to do as a country to move
forward yeah
and because it's reported that the
government targeted this area because of
the zip code everybody in a sense is a
survivor yeah tarika thank you very much